foreign
[Music] what's up super sexy rejects we are
watching a movie today that has a title and
and um and that's your intro see on the other
side
okay that's good enough we watch soccer and
Dale Versus Evil and Roxy has never seen Roxy
I never even heard of this until until I messaged
her asking if you've seen it you said are
you making titles up and now full disclosure
what does the YouTube safe word for this I
took a lot of food gummy stuff when I saw
this when it first came out over a decade
ago all I remembered was going that was fun
can't tell you a single detail about this
movie literally have no idea how the act one
two or three goes you know they're three acts
though I am assuming it's a movie yeah maybe
it's a 10 hack structure you see this is like
five out of five stars and I've never heard
of it when you texted it to me I thought it
was part of the Ash versus evil dead franchise
hey can you ask them to leave a like yeah
guys don't forget it's very important like
comment subscribe tell your friends so we
get more sexy Rejects what's the voice I don't
know are you doing a koi impression maybe
no I'd have to talk way quicker than that
yeah and you have to yell like comment subscribe
leave all the things yeah you're doing the
face at least he really does he gets big in
the face and also uh yeah thanks for clarifying
yeah and uh also uh fully Reaction watch the
lock screen with your own coffee those are
the sexy rejects the patriots the patriots
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah that's a good point
but you should all be patrons by now because
that's where the sexy people are yeah listen
to the woman with the hair that's an inside
joke I do have hair how's it doing today not
ideal it's good enough that's how you compliment
people when we were starting I was fixing
my hair and he said you're fine and then he
said look you look like a waitress which is
right now listen this intro is going on way
too long no it's not this is what the people
want this is what the people want yep try
editing a video with her and koi it's her
total blast that's what I hear I hear we're
a great pair are you sure we should be doing
this this is still a crime scene stack up
Billy it's called investigative journalism
for a reason what do you say Billy want a
Peabody Award look great up on you oh no
foreign
not the slightest bit familiar we wouldn't
have thought to bring this okay I I stand
correctly you
[Music]
hey guys what's going on we forgot the beer
that would suck
can I help you hey Chad do we need more bugs
Chad they're all douchebags
kind of looks like John if he gain like 100
pounds pickled eggs six pounder you oh hot
dog Tucker have you ever seen anything like
that in your life there's nothing so special
about them the noise in my ear pickled eggs
you gotta have some faith in yourself man
girls can smell fear now come on you are a
good looking man more or less [Laughter] what's
the worst that can happen
oh my God your childhood fears get activated
you're right tuck I'm gonna do it all right
I'm gonna do it right now you gotta chew and
swallow my dude smile on left okay all right
why does she have that Grim Reaper oh what
a dumbass you guys uh going camping
look we don't want any trouble all right so
just oh
poor guy John does not have that problem this
is that's a giver giv apostrophe ER
you know what your problem is you got an inferiority
complex no I don't yeah yeah nope let me tell
you something life is short you got to go
after what you want sure sure as hell ain't
gonna just fall right in your lap that's true
I reckon oh [__] what are you doing oh
what a dumbass we used to call these Road
sodas oh no [Music]
get up my hand is stuck it
yeah
howdy officer we are headed to our vacation
home up by Morris Lake me and Dale here we're
gonna go fix her up maybe do a little fishing
do a little fishing
bigger little man time might do them some
good three nothing up there but pain is suffering
on a scale you can't even imagine oh okay
that must be the evil you got broken turn
signal oh yes sir get that fixed that was
very helpful yes as they are PSA drinking
and driving is no joke that's true that's
very true but riding in the passenger seat
having a beer oh harmless
we're a little more okay with it
I really uh like the inverse on these two
of how they present them like their typical
hillbilly villains and then your spot out
there just soft guys
did they establish what the real are they
Brothers maybe just besties whoever used to
live here must have been a an archaeologist
or something yeah yeah
look at this must have been a real News Junkie
too
I'm a sort of real news by three get two free
no expiration date all right no experience
dreams really do come true oh my God oh holy
moly fix that yeah that's a good idea
you can get off of me now they have such cute
energy I know and you want to hear a real
story yep it was 20 years ago today
[Laughter] that's so dumb [Music] hey man
what the hell are you doing yeah
[Music]
there's a logic too foreign
that is the color green of the film [Music]
oh only one person lived to tell this story
who's the one the killer who wants to go skinny-dipping
I do let's go all right oh maybe the police
officer was the one person I care taking this
mystery very serious I appreciate that you
asked you know you can drop the act now what
act like you're better than everyone else
you are better than everyone else
you and I Ali are Cut From a Different Cloth
what is happening she's done nothing to show
this I know I think he's just really attracted
her
it's a good thing it lowers my inhibitions
well why why stop you're gross
let's talk about this later I'm gonna go catch
up with everyone I'm gonna catch up with everyone
you don't find him attractive uh just for
some reason no but I do know 50 of him
I think we should go check it out good luck
I'm glad we chose this movie it's a good movie
for this moment right here have you seen 30
Rock
oh [__] they look painful is she okay
you do not yell out my name well you were
being a Peeping Tom you were hopeless do you
know that you're hopeless no I think that's
respectful she don't push your woke agendas
during my Tucker and Dale Versus Evil good
point good point go vocal broke respectful
where'd you go Chuck oh he is a sweetheart
he got it
I don't know how they just keep mistakenly
we got your friend it's a gun they got Allison
this guy is
your friend while the hell are they running
away this is great getting misinterpreted
such a funny idea or Hillbillies heavily from
the store lesson it's time to rise to the
occasion man what you gonna do Chad
they captured her by canoe bandana see yeah
more bandages I'm wearing a bandage right
now I could mess with a bandana imagine I've
said reject on it that'd be sick product placement
product placement income
I think I should ask pancakes
poor guy poor guy honestly I could mess with
some pancakes I know and a bandana it's just
a cabin it doesn't mean they're psycho Killers
Psycho Killer then why don't you go in there
and talk to them all right maybe I will is
he new here I can recognize him he's got a
name tag yeah he works here oh oh you don't
remember okay uh well uh Man Tucker I mean
uh uh I and Tuck [Music] Tucker and I brung
you here that's my dog drinkers he he looks
mean but he's just a big old marshmallow you
can just pet him around the nose it's drooling
I know Tucker just bought this place and uh
you know I'm sure it doesn't look like much
to a high class girl like you oh but uh anyway
you should relax and rest okay he is so cute
what's your name it's tail Ducker tell him
my name do you guys have anything to to do
around here do you like board games what kind
do you have
yes come on four to seven no wait you went
too early one two three do you go one two
three then go Rock Paper Scissors Shoot oh
it's not not bad that's cut that Bostonian
[__] out of here man La rock paper scissors
that's where you go shooting on scissors yeah
whatever we need to watch the movie it's not
a coin Roxy reaction better much you know
me yeah
sending in the guy we don't know so something's
gonna happen
Mitchell parts
so he has a really good lock on perspective
with switching between them all right
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right [Laughter] oh no
I knew he was gonna die I knew it these kills
are actually pretty good does it be yeah it's
already released
in that moment he realized he knew who was
the fifth president of the United States oh
that's too easy that's James Monroe God you
were right again did you know that obviously
not I barely made it past the third grade
hey this
[Music] is a lot to say yeah keep telling
yourself that I'm getting my Bachelor's degree
in Psychology oh oh so what kind of work would
you do with that so many of the major problems
and conflicts in the world are caused by a
lack of communication you know yeah hey hey
oh my God Tucker what happened to your face
I sought into a business why well I didn't
do it on purpose why
wow
we came out here to work oh no it should arrived
playing stupid board games
hey how about I come over here and I pull
those stingers out of your face and then I'll
help you with whatever you want all right
I'd block that thank you okay I've never been
stung by a bee no they it sucks it's not real
wood
plastic
just leave let's go outside and knock on somewhere
we'll go find a friends you should relax Tucker
and Dale are on the case I get that right
Tucker
yeah do you think he saw that the friend died
no I want to let Tucker do most of the talking
anyway he can win over just about anybody
can't you Tucker real people person
okay here we go
me neither he's amazing he's so good you [__]
quit it with this thing okay it doesn't work
out here oh we gotta get to the road why did
he break cause Chad's the worst survival of
the fish oh God whoa not bad what are you
doing man that's my whole face somebody's
coming oh [__] oh [__] you left the
ax
and they're hiding behind a fairies it's a
hatchet
Pilots kid
College hey College counts Carla's kids laughs
maybe we could leave them a note in case they
come back careful I'm gonna have to etch it
in probably took them an hour I know I feel
like it took a very very long time
we got your friend you think that girl is
hot yeah she said that problems come down
to lack of communication and that's all that's
happening in this movie hello hello
what huh what what's this outfit not a waitress
tell you that much where did she find it I
don't know oh yeah good question you mind
if I help what no no no no no it's not work
for a pretty for a girl like you that's oh
whoa I grew up on a farm it's either help
out or get out oh man she's perfect you know
what I mean for what you know just a perfect
human appreciate yeah we need more for them
perfect for Dale I'm just curious about where
these pants came from
oh those are so scary yeah sick he's making
her dig her own grave this movie's really
kind of clever it's very clever I'm shocked
I haven't heard of this no oh good looking
friends are here hey [Music] oh no
oh
no that's two people death by like dagger
through them
oh well it's pretty obvious it's gonna happen
to this guy
he just died right in there foreign oh my
God oh my God [Laughter] I love the way that
was shot it just like straight open to another
of God what happened to you
some kid you talked himself right into the
wood chipper let's head first right into the
wood chipper it looked like it might have
been one of the colors because what the hell
happened to her she got knocked down fell
into the [__] hole right next to me is
that your blood no it's college kid blood
college kid let's come running out of nowhere
in spirit cell spectrums holy crap
I
know what this is what this is a side pack
oh my God you're coming out here and they're
killing themselves all over the woods oh my
God that makes so much sense sharp objects
I think they're trying to kill her too that's
why they acted so funny after we saved her
because they want her dead oh my God we'll
go to the police it's a good idea Dale oh
Heidi Ho officer we've had a doozy of a day
there we were minding our own business just
doing some chores around the house when kids
started killing themselves all over my property
what matters is what looks like what happened
and what looks like what happened is pretty
nasty his voice is amazing
that scene had me I was laughing so hard my
high star water yeah yeah you really killed
him that was that was so funny
you guys are all a bunch of [__] okay
Chad your two BFFs are dead but do you know
how lucky you all are huh what the f are you
talking about man there's no rules out here
it's us against them no no there are rules
you don't think you can handle that maybe
you deserve to die why is Chad so evil that's
[__] up yeah check out the police come
here come on you guys let's go no you don't
need the cops oh my God this guy's awesome
thing what is he so afraid of maybe he's running
he's the one with the inferiority complex
oh God
climb in the back seat and we'll go have a
look
Chad's God Rogue this door had better not
charge me for this yep oh look I'm gonna wedge
it from that side and you pull them out on
three says there no actual evil in this movie
Chad's evil
oh my God no no do not try [Laughter] stop
this is my kind of stupid guy
oh [__]
this is bad you can't stay put
I'll handle this
is he gonna die good to see you again yeah
we have had a doozy of a day all of a sudden
out of nowhere these kids started killing
themselves all over my property
you must think some kind of a [__] believes
story like that no oh no no sir not morons
open-minded you say you are just working when
this kid ran up and stuffed his head into
that wood chipper yeah it is a fact and I
think maybe they might be trying to kill the
girl that we have
look you know what she can maybe explain the
whole thing if if uh if I hadn't knocked her
unconscious with a shovel bedroom
[Music] [Laughter]
wait wait where's it going no no why would
the cop not have his gun out already I don't
know now you're looking at least two counts
of involuntary manslaughter officer do we
look like a couple psycho Killers to you yes
well it's it's hard to say yeah
oh no you okay
oh [__]
oh my God
damn who directed this movie he takes the
gun
will fix the fiend I'm like who wrote it oh
you gotta take the safety off on the side
there oh no oh my gosh
I love this River Chad what the [__] you're
something Dale I don't know none of this would
have happened if it wasn't for you oh let's
save her oh let's save her well at least she's
still alive she's the only one none of this
would have happened if we hadn't gone fishing
that isn't even an option I don't even like
this
what do you mean you don't like fishing I
mean I like it okay I'm sorry I'm sorry Tucker
did I hurt your feet the ultimate betrayal
I'm sorry
no don't let the dog get shot
did you bring that nail gun in here yeah why
stay low stay low to the ground keep your
head not to roll
challenge kids
where'd the Dog go oh you like that college
kids how's that tasting I'll play more where
that came from a bunch of freaks they are
a bunch of freaks bring out the girl I'm gonna
shoot your dog
[Music] no college kids are faster except
he uses his uh inhaler that's good good attention
and detail he caught him
oh no this is taking a dramatic turn he's
awake
he's like why are you guys doing this what
the hell is wrong with you kids payback time
hillbilly stay back for what it's for Mike
no
oh no but what'd he do did he cut off his
hand oh did he I don't know it was a weird
shot I couldn't tell we heard the acts and
then test audiences didn't respond well to
actually seeing the violence I thought it
was his ear he cut off your gas as good as
mine but I think my guess is better
it's good to cry sometimes
Allison you need to get out there she needs
to get out there and talk to them man they
don't know what's happening they think that
they're trying to kill her I know she should
go out there and explain it she hasn't told
her well it's hard to say um your friends
do some of your friends take medication yeah
first I thought they were trying to kill you
and then they started killing themselves and
then [Music] the love is concept nobody wants
to hurt you it sure sounds like someone does
I'm gonna go talk to them okay say your idea
oh my God
oh no
they chopped off what hand right oh it's kind
of small for a hand are you a finger I think
it could fit there that's from Tucker's shirt
what is that uh I gotta go help Tucker God
damn it my best friend needs me I'm gonna
get these kids they must have thought that
you're trying to harm me oh and why would
they think that
I don't know I think you do know oh I thought
that I looked like some kind of freak we mistjudged
you Dale I there's a message I'm really sorry
don't judge a book by its cover
that was the dumbest most amazing
goddamn stupid college kids [Laughter] Tucker
please no way
oh I never thought I'd say this but I'm glad
I'm not hunting like a bear
sorry about that
I haven't done anything to me Chad this has
all been a huge misunderstanding we have to
burn this place to the ground no no no no
no no Chad chat gasoline games over there
no tap no chat stop stop wait a minute I remember
reading about this in my Sociology class I
don't think it's stock Stockholm has been
kidnapped ends up falling in love with their
kidnapper that's one way to find love
I'll try it next to you let the girl go you
okay Ali did he just call you Ally wait I
make some tea and and we all sit and and talk
this out oh yeah it sounds like a good idea
I'll provide the figure sandwiches finger
soon
is that chamomile tea because I kind of have
that it [__] with my asthma [Laughter]
no asthma's gonna come back again I want you
each to tell your side of the story see yourself
in their shoes okay not bad not bad understand
each other's perspective before any progress
can be made you have a career Chad why don't
you start well where should I begin wherever
you'd like
before I was born okay maybe not that far
important you see my parents Hillbillies just
like him
my mother ran for a life oh she was the only
Survivor no I think maybe he's the only person
who lived is he there it was before he was
born no how would he be born then
[Laughter]
well they torture
oh that's cruel she fought back and she escaped
good cop but my father wasn't so lucky
generally horrifying yeah and a good reason
to not like some people I guess my mom
Chad said they would go longer than 15 minutes
we come in guns blazing woman don't argue
with me yeah woman are they drinking tea I
would totally love a cup of tea right now
same sorry we don't provide that here at the
real reject Studio
it's cold it's just how I like it it's your
turn um okay okay well but you got Dale first
of all I'm really sorry that your family got
massacred yes that's awful
that's right that's the lesson I can't even
hurt fish that's right you can't even hurt
a fish so now that you've both expressed your
side of the story did they I feel I feel better
I feel neither talked about the story
[Music] my God no
oh
nice go back to hell where you belong freak
oh no and all the gasoline
oh [__] you wanted to smoke a cigarette
but they worked so hard for their vacation
home I know goddamn college kids [Music] oh
my God her face
[__] Kevin I'm so sad
I'm a terrible therapist what I thought you
did a great job in there really yeah really
oh he's gonna come out smoke is not good for
somebody with asthma though ah yes good catch
I think that we should go to the pickup truck
right now wait wait should help him oh never
mind [Laughter] this this is [Music]
I'm so upset about the house understandable
how he's gonna hit a tree he's gonna hit a
tree
what is happening to our protagonist well
Alan tudik said be careful with this it's
the only thing I had left so you knew they
were gonna crash it I never should have talked
to Allison he were right people like me and
people like her just don't mix it's not true
that's not what he said do you remember when
we was a kid and we used to go catch frogs
down at that Creek so maybe Brothers remember
our Lifeline how we used to compete to see
who could catch more yeah I don't think now
is the time to talk about Tucker I didn't
let you catch more you caught him on your
own it was quicker than I was come on Tucker
no way you're better than you think you are
that girl sees it I've seen the way that the
two of you look at each other really sees
you for who you are oh so maybe after this
is all done you two can on a date cue the
music I wanted more negativity
strong and you're not as ugly as you think
you are
that means a lot coming from you he's so cute
both of them are so sweet I know she needs
you now more than ever especially because
you always falling down and hitting her head
first rare best friends forever they're just
friends okay we figured it out sometimes siblings
are friends
thank you that hurt very much breathing out
through your mouth oh my God go get her it's
so cute do me a favor anything kick the [__]
out of that little College [__] for me
would you yeah can you stay here okay come
on let's go wow this movie is really good
I know he probably shot it on the cheap cheap
it's got heart it's goofy so much heart it's
so clever too yeah clever and it riffs on
the genre in such a unique way
you what is happening now I'm willing to forgive
you but you're gonna have to package
I was just not a very nice apology kiss es
we're making up he's so crispy
ah sorry that's gross he's so crunchy what
are these adjectives you have chosen for me
so crispy and crunchy don't you feel like
his skin is like charred yeah
oh my God now he gets the dress up
the real Iron Man
[Music] you you want to help me here oh yeah
hang on hang on her outfit is the biggest
mystery of the whole thing like I'm supposed
to believe those are one of those guys pants
you never know man could have been like pants
goals you know he's from the betrayed me Allison
no can't kill Allison [Music] no okay okay
where did he come from [Music] oh nicely done
Dale
they actually kill her off no no way zero
percent chance yeah he gives it to her was
that intentional holy crap it's time for you
to feel my pain bring it frat [__] bring
it frat [__]
she has no butt crack why are you judging
her not jealous the lack of that butt crack
what come here and look at this his parents
are the ones who actually killed everybody
look at the guy in the middle oh yeah he said
his mother was captured my father's body was
never found I think we first found him oh
that's your real father no no it's true Chad
you're half hillbilly he lied to me oh goodness
to protect you [Music]
reaction in rare cases where people are allergic
to it
but he'll be okay as long as we get him his
inhaler
[Music] get him his inhaler
you know she's good yeah she's very good I
just remember her on 30 Rock I thought she
was there to be pretty she's actually like
really good here I just saw her in this movie
sex drive she's getting it yeah I wonder what
what she's been up to recently she has a ton
of credits hey buddy how you feeling I'm feeling
high on prescription medication yeah they
found my fingers check it out
I remember that one looking that way they
look funny to you no no not really it's a
big beauty
that Andy straw your favorite sipping utensil
yum bigger out of a straw did you ask her
out for God's sake oh well yes he did I never
actually got the chance so no but you're hopeless
yeah you're probably right about that except
for yep she's a pretty darn good bowler so
we're going bowling
you little [__] I'm out of here [Music]
ow she is a good bowler that girl has got
an amazing shot bowling fingers I know you
have to go after what you want because it
sure is heck fire ain't just gonna fall right
into your lap and just be yourself okay yeah
oh my gosh do you know what that is yes it's
a it's a helmet Ah that's a cute gift it's
perfect
so listen Dale I'm uh I'm really sorry about
everything that happened do you think they'll
kiss I hope so just you know what let me just
let me just say this because I don't know
if we're ever gonna get to spend this kind
of time together again yeah I just want to
let you know
I see it I'm like in love with him really
yeah really [Music]
oh my God should we go help her hell no it's
just happened he went after what he wanted
and who knows whatever [Music]
it's really creepy I don't know Craig yeah
you know me like Craig yeah come on he like
Craig sounds like he's part of my tribe but
I don't know who it is wow that was really
really good all right Roxy take it away what
did you think of the movie really surprisingly
good not surprising because you had told me
that it was good but surprising that I've
never heard of this movie and it feels like
it should be up there with some of those mid-2000s
comedies yeah it's a solid horror comedy it's
like does both so well mm-hmm yeah definitely
but like even it's like less horror and more
comedy than even like a scary movie kind of
thing I think maybe equal really I feel like
it's definitely scary movies this is Gory
I guess I think they did a great job on really
committing to the like the it wouldn't be
as funny if it wasn't as violent yeah totally
the like massive angle of it yeah we got to
say the word on a live on YouTube oh the on
the mass unalived yeah they unalived themselves
they did it though it was just all by accident
that's just like the funny part yeah because
easily this could have been a movie in which
they were the bad guys and whatever but the
fact that it was all like coincidence sake
that was really clever yeah and it had this
like sweet heart I really did because like
there's been like a couple of movies I watched
like Daredevil again here on the channel because
I had a similar experience where I was like
I don't remember this I'm gonna watch it but
I was like once in a while something would
pop up and Daredevil that would go oh yeah
and I I remember the scene I didn't remember
any of this movie really wow I think it was
just two too big yeah well this would be a
perfect movie to watch while you're like that
because it's funny as hell I know I remembered
going that was funny yeah but I don't remember
like Jack about the actual movie it's so strange
that we really liked so many of these actors
and we haven't and and they've all seems like
they've all worked but that they like none
of them blew up other than Alan Tudyk I guess
well I imagine this is more of the cult hit
because I watched this on I don't remember
when I first watched this I must it was like
on some random stream it might have been Netflix
or something uh way back in the day and it
was just a random thing I put on when I was
like binging horror movies so I didn't even
know I was like going into a horror comedy
I think whatever my memory tells me regardless
yeah you're right though like these actors
were so good even even the Chad character
yeah he's really good he I loved how he and
they all knew the kind of tone and genre they
were in the whole time you need like the whole
cast on the on the right wavelength and I
think they all found that like no one tipped
the access point too much I thought this was
really well executed what was the impetus
for this today like did you see it pop up
somewhere are people talking about this right
now nice impetus oh good choice of words super
smart damn that you know actually I'm more
like Dale I don't I don't know how smart I
am but I do remember words oh seriously for
the impetus I don't even know what that word
means what was the like reasoning behind what
was the thing my Yusuf in a sentence I have
eventually figured it out um but uh I don't
know it was it was one of the things on my
list that I came across it on the streaming
I was like like I said for years I just keep
going I should re-watch this because I I don't
remember anything about it and decide I just
wanted to watch it I think we've had a couple
of recommend I think someone recommended it
when we did Jennifer's Body and that and that
was what made me add it to the list of like
yeah I really do want to watch that again
that one leans more horror this one is like
I would call this it was a straight up comedy
it was straight it was sharp yeah it's like
a sharp comedy um because the the beginning
part of it I'm like okay there's something
about the grimy aesthetic that's a little
off-putting then you realize how the budget
is very it feels purposeful they lean into
it it doesn't try to mask its budget like
it actually helps elevate it the fact that
it's so low budget and it has that kind of
grimy scuzzy quality to it because it's the
kind of genre of like the the old school like
Texas Chainsaw Massacre or Friday the 13th
movies that had that kind of film grain totaliness
to it and and I thought they did such a good
job of like it's it's it's a it's really smart
it's smart because like the character it's
got the kind of dumb comedy in the sense of
like these characters are are a little dumb
sure but it's smart dumb comedy to me and
I thought they did such a great job on hopping
back and forth between the perspectives of
you get why Tucker and Dale view the situation
this way and you get why the college kids
view the situation this way and the way they
because and I love how it they do have this
like sense the sensibility about communication
at its core and that being the detriment to
what landed them all in the situation because
they all judged each other to us it's surprisingly
smart instead of just gags you know yeah I
think that both you and I as writers like
we're picking up on the fact that they really
put a ton into like planting those seeds and
also like you said dealing with the budget
that they had there's like almost no extras
in this it almost entirely takes place in
one location or like one Campground kind of
thing um we've got a limited cast that are
there and then they use the same type of like
anything we're using the whoop chipper for
that's also going to be a death if there's
a bunch of trees around that's gonna be multiple
deaths we know if there's water that's going
to be on issue like they really use their
environment in this yeah I in such a cool
way that was that was really surprising the
ending was a Bizarro moment but I think we're
just gonna let that go yeah there's a bit
of uh above Macabre Huber to it it was really
a dark keyword in in that moment I was like
I don't know what's happening or is he just
kidnapping this girl maybe the message is
like yes you should go after what you want
but like maybe that advice doesn't work for
all people because some people are creeps
there are some actual creepy Hillbillies out
there who need to be stopped yeah what did
you think about the reveal about uh who is
his daddy was Luke I am your father uh I thought
that was I thought that was funny it was it
was handled in a way that because the mystery
is not like the most engaging part about it
uh but they I I like that they cared to put
some TLC towards the the mystery yeah totally
and the the you're half Hill
they played they played it so straight yeah
their delivery on it they really believe what
they're saying at least you know it's like
it's a great act it's just great acting like
they really believe what they're saying and
that's what made it so funny like I never
felt I feel like nowadays it's gonna sound
like a total insult it is uh is that if they'd
made this movie like today like just 10 plus
years from now right I feel like it would
just be like social media actors they would
cast in like people who were like famous on
Tick Tock or whatever influencers influencers
is what you mean by social media actor yes
that is that's correct impetus absolutely
not um yeah I know what you mean the the alley
Katrina Bowden was so Earnest is it Bowden
or boating Bowden I don't know b-o-w-d-e-n
so Bo then maybe uh for some reason I think
it's about it maybe that's because I used
to date somebody with the last name about
it um what happened there this is a very very
but a bummer I messed it up I'm sorry yeah
thanks I reached out a few years ago he didn't
know oh really I'm sorry I was like hey maybe
he'll see this video kind of don't think so
what's up friend um sorry yeah I know I'll
never move on I sounds like a great guy
yeah I totally agree anyway yeah no he he
essentially was Dale oh really like interpersonality
wise or physical wise both neither
it's like a six foot blotting for the white
guy he was a frat guy so maybe he's more like
Chad yeah he's the problem anyway there you
go yeah it was good it's good to open up about
these things on camera yeah anyway bowdance
so yeah Katrina photos anyway she's super
early she's good yeah she's really really
good in there this is a good word for it yeah
and if she wasn't it would have sucked that's
true I mean I I I've seen all of 30 Rock on
another show I'm like I've seen all of it
don't really remember it but my associate
my memory with things is often like I remember
how I felt about it I don't remember me too
that's what I always say I don't remember
plot points in a movie but I remember how
it made me feel yeah and and I remember her
character in that show just essentially just
being there to be pretty and I don't remember
ever her actually standing out and unless
I'm remembering that wrong because here I
was like oh she's actually like there's a
sincerity to her performance that feels very
believable she was like ditzier on the show
right yeah she was more like pretty blonde
itsy girl like she's the the model character
and then here she's she's so much more than
that and she's believable yeah very believable
and a perfect the perfect energy balance uh
for the characters of Tucker and Dale I hope
they get married I hope so too Tucker and
their chemistry is so solid those they have
like amazing chemistry too the to the point
where we thought there might be siblings even
though they look nothing alike oh that's not
who you're talking about now yeah yeah Tucker
yeah okay you know they're actors they I mean
people who don't they don't I don't think
David Schwimmer and Courtney Cox look alike
kind of do you really well I'm just saying
these actors they weren't brothers so they
need to look alike but yeah siblings don't
look alike all the time I'm just saying we
didn't think that they were siblings because
all of a sudden they're on screen and we're
like oh they're identical we thought they're
certain things they had such great chemistry
yeah that's a fair point did I get you defensive
I'm sorry about David Shore and Courtney Fox
yeah thing yeah I'm pissed yeah it's just
a really stand up for my friends Courtney
Cox and um David Schumer are both like brunettes
yeah that's true
that's all it takes similarities David Henry
and Selena Gomez and what is the Waverly Place
or siblings in that show and and they don't
look alike or they do they don't oh I mean
he's like pure white oh he's like the whitest
kid your bread Pure White the best white but
they also are both brunette yeah so it works
casting wise um I never thought about that
that's funny and uh yeah and this and uh I
think the wrestling Ensemble was fine too
you know like the physical gag bits I think
I love that wood chipper moment so much because
you saw it coming you were like oh it's all
but I think the way they that's what I loved
about it's like the way they executed it because
they make it so obvious like they're telling
the audience he's going to die like he's going
to jump into somehow he's going to land in
the wood chipper right and I think your mind
goes down like oh he's gonna like trip into
it or something yeah he just like straight
dives into it totally as if it was a purpose
is that if it was purposeful and so they totally
surprised me and how and how he gets into
the wood chipper imagine how shocked you would
be if you were bloating wood into a wood chip
or you ducked down to load would you go back
up and there's legs yeah and he tried saving
him too are you okay yeah I love the escalation
of their performances this movie had a lot
of heart and more it had just the right amount
of like nuanced sensibility to not make it
because this is the kind of plot that could
have worn thin too early on even for a short
movie I hear you who do you feel like you'd
recommend this to like people who love what
movie oh boy um like did you think that this
is for the like super bad Step Brothers group
of people or is it for the people who love
um scary movie or is it for people who love
Friday the 13th and loves like I think I think
yeah like the horror crowd would like this
movie a lot I think people who if we're talking
about I think this is more of the spoof uh
category even though it's not full spoof but
it's it's like right there so it's like the
Edgar Wright spoof level in a way where it's
not only being a spoof it's just it's being
its own movie with characters and everything
whereas like scary movie is I would call that
a parody movie you know and where this is
it does spoof on the genre but it decides
to extend beyond that and I think that's what
was so impressive about it we're talking so
serious about this comedy and I love it because
I respect this movie for what it did I have
a lot of respect for this film respect I really
wish I could go watch more of the director
and Writer's work I don't know what happened
I think this might have been one of those
memories that became a cold hit over time
and so yeah you just kind of don't generate
work when it came out you think that people
aren't talking about it I don't remember because
it was kind of before I was in the space you
haven't even the space of what like this what
we're doing right now that's the only reason
you ever heard of this movie no I'm saying
I wasn't that what no in 2010 I just wasn't
really in the movie space like I was not like
paying attention to what was out there and
things like that oh so you before you were
doing this you were actually not as you just
you just weren't because I was always like
kind of obsessed with knowing about stuff
even before I started doing I'm a die-hard
television person got it I always have been
and then and always saw like the big tentpole
movies and and I did love movies but something
like this that you're saying maybe was didn't
catch on till later there's a lot of stuff
right around this time period like 2008 9
10 11. right yeah if it was a deeper cut I
probably didn't hear it no you you didn't
you didn't even hear about this that's what
I find so surprising like I've I've heard
this in the conversation I'm pretty sure it
was recommended to specifically us you grew
up watching cult movies not a lot I was uh
what kind of would horror a little bit more
um and you heard of this at the time I had
heard about Tucker and Dale Versus Evil being
good I did not know it was a horror I didn't
know it was a comedy horror film I thought
it was gonna be more of a horror film um for
[__] yeah yeah well done uh thank you
I thought it would be more of that but now
this surprised me and I I don't know thank
you guys for the recommendation yeah thanks
everyone you did it I'm glad you enjoyed it
you seemed like you enjoyed it yeah I thought
it was bomb it was awesome I love when I watch
movies here and then I go and I tell all my
friends like you gotta go check out blah blah
and then watch my reaction And subscribe to
the real rejects yeah that's exactly what
I say hey you start getting tagged and [__]
now that's dope I saw that I've been seeing
that on Twitter and stuff yep listen what
did I tell you I grow on beautiful like a
fungus what did I tell you I'm a fun game
you're the fun guy you're the fun guy they
call me the fun girl fun girl fun girl
[Music]
maybe it could happen a girl a girl can dream
one day when you and koi and Michael start
buying actual real rejects or I'll just hook
you guys up what who looks more like David
Schwimmer and Courtney Cox or me and you what
what the hell did you just say what is it
what is your question who looks more alike
you and I are or David Schwimmer and Courtney
Cox ah
you know a lot of people think have mistaken
me for being Jewish for my whole life really
I could see it really yeah I can see it too
yeah I could see it a lot of people have mistaken
me for not being Jewish um anyway anyway now
that we're here let's send this guys thank
you so much for being here uh you could follow
rocks in the world girls totally forgot to
promote that at the beginning of this also
uh subscribe and uh you check us on patreon
and hey uh Roxy can you help me in this the
patron of the day shout out um all right I
wonder what do you got who do you got well
you know I tell you before I used to say grown
people like a fungus yeah yeah I would say
grown people like us mother bleach and then
I heard that they suck on people Mark Leach
everyone
oh the way to pick that yes um oh hi Mark
you know try should I pull out whatever you
can no I'm shouting on Mark because a that
was a room reference B e um you can suck on
us anytime you heard me Mark Leach see you've
got a dope name and our dope Patron and super
sexy that was d a b c d um and this smile
is for you oh that's really sweet I know I've
gotta know Mark pretty well actually okay
tell me more tell me more did he get very
fun he's from UK he's had kind of a crazy
year ooh he's had a crazy year you know I
love sometimes we talk about our struggles
he's had some pretty crazy struggles okay
well then he really deserved this smile yeah
he did and he deserves something really positive
like what you dispelled his way because yeah
dispelled look at who's bringing the vocab
now ah honestly I question if I used it correct
I don't know sometimes I say words and I wait
for the other person to be like a little nod
I'm like okay I guess I used it right it's
not my thing yeah that's why I write because
I have a thesaurus ready if I disposal at
any moment um but Mark my dude I really feel
like this year is going to be a big turnaround
for you I feel like there's a lot of positive
energy coming your way yep I can feel it too
and I appreciate you for being a massive support
in our lives for so long and you know what
dude you are you you he has he's a he has
a really gentle heart okay well this one's
for you then Mark my your name is Mark you
should enjoy the park because you're not an
arc and that is
far Squad Stark Tony you're our own Tony style
there you go
foreign [Music]